[Music]
everybody thanks for coming
just a couple about myself I've been in
a quant in EBS doing this delicately
options and then a doji during FX swaps
and then just across as a project which
mostly involve eight curves so I fit
fitted a lot of curves in my working
life and about two years ago I've left
finance to have some more fun with
machine learning and AI
which is what I'm focusing on these days
across different domains and machine
learning and neural networks noticed I
was terribly fun but sometimes or
usually the simplest tricks are the best
so what I'm trying we'll try to show you
today are the tricks that I found very
useful to me for dealing with hugely
over parameterize curves so generally
what has been a technique I found very
useful when you're trying to fit some
kind of a curve or time series or any
kind of objects a change in time is to
badly over parameterize them have way
way way too many parameters to begin
with in the model and then take them
away with math as you need to and here
is how this could work first of all
let's look at regularization in a really
tight problem severely undetermined we
have 10 points we have a fully non
parametric model with 10 parameters and
the metrics 8 to go from parameters to
points and we know the values of three
points by the way let me just let me
this thing is even github um let me zoom
that up right so if you just go to
github to this to this URL you can
download it and run it it doesn't
require anything much oh yes okay um so
let's begin with the first problem which
is really related to one three ten
points three window and we'd like to fit
a nice curve to those points fully
nonparametric what does you know if you
just hired somebody out straight of
university out of academia what do they
do a first attempts SVD of
pseudo-inverse or some such linear
algebra tree so let's take a look how
does it go we take a our matrix a for
now is identity so parameter is equal
points and we know through the eyes of
three points and we will try to reduce
the others pseudo-inverse for the
parameter vector we plot them not so
nice
we have those points and matched
everything as a zero okay second attempt
regularization always the problems on
the determinant so you can just invert
it so a regularization and people thing
regularization they think Ridge
regression ok Ridge regression
scikit-learn around that
okay
run the strange a long time and then
it's loaded it's the same result which
is unsurprising because regression just
penalizes a bit Eliza's coefficient
values so all the collisions don't have
to be zero that's are the other
conditions that don't have to be nonzero
are zero
still boring now let's make it even more
fun let's have our matrix a be really
weird so let's have our identity on the
diagonal and then just add random
numbers all over the place so I have my
AR is identity plus random normal and do
the same thing now it looks
substantially worse not surprisingly
because now the coefficients match the
points we have to match but now because
the with the right columns of a but now
because all the columns of a I ran them
the other points are all over the place
and Ridge regression same thing so what
do we do about it we stop for a moment
and think of what is actually going on
what is going on is that you have far
more degrees of freedom than you need to
match your points so rather than try to
just hide them under the rug with
regression you can make those extra
degrees of freedom do things for you for
example you can you can make them you
can define any extra constraint and add
that to yoke and add that to your
original equation and you can give it
extra constraint a tiny tiny weight and
then the original thing will be
satisfied and your extra constraint will
also be satisfied without damaging your
original constraint measurable so and if
you do them and if you do the linear
algebra first which I'm sorry I don't
have the latest at the latex two but
here is a function and that's basically
linear regression with a regularization
term thrown it and if you do this and my
first regularizer I take is just a first
derivative so I penalize differences
between between adjacent values and then
what happens that's
okay at least the points are flowed in
isolation we have nicely constant and
linear now Oh
what happens if you take the second
derivative just square the matrix okay
not that's already much better so now
we've taken 300 points and without
imposing any function any kind of
specific functional form we've fitted in
that nice curve and we've defined what
nice means if you want to penalize third
derivatives akin to that and if you want
to impose other things you can do that
and nice thing is when problems
undetermined
this is costless with this with regard
to your regional objective because if it
was extra degrees of freedom you give
you a new term super low weight and the
original equations still hold okay so
far um and this also works for a messy
parametrization it doesn't matter
because our penalty works on the values
and not on the coefficients then if we
get to run the same thing with the next
matrix a with lots of random numbers we
still get it inactive and that's a
genuinely nice property of working with
regular risers rather than is that you
can have you can ignore your parameters
ation just work with what you have with
what it was coming up okay now obviously
normally you do have some values
everywhere just very nice values so let
us create a curve um so for example here
I've taken a side chunk of a sine curve
which is blue and then generated random
bids and asks around it some of them are
why some of them are tight that's very
realistic quoting inside my liquid
markets so you observe the green dips
you just observe the green beige that
asks the male's I calculate it and your
objective is to reconstruct the blue
curve and now you see that if you just
look at the mids then the bits where
then the bits where one side is very
very wide will throw you off but those
knees are not real right the tank
meat is here it's not mean anything what
what all the only thing that it means is
that you have a bid here and ask here so
that fair value could be anywhere in
here and not just in the middle so how
do we encode that um we we do exactly
the same thing as before except we add a
weighting term to our regression all we
do here is um again what this limit of
the math is in the code but
fundamentally a weighted least squares
regression with the regularization term
and the weights are the inverse of the
bid-ask spreads and that's a theme that
again it's totally simple trick that I
found immensely useful that bid-ask
spreads our confidence intervals that
helps when you fit across a curve that
fits really health that helps me fit
across time that helps when you when you
merge two different sources for the same
price for example or it's so it really
helps to to give you the regulating so
let's define the news the new solver
which just uses the weight as the errors
in the values and what that looks like
and years and you see from the code I'm
being brave because I'm generating the
digit asks on the fly so this is this
stuff is random so I did not I did not
carefully pick the curve for the stuff
to come out eyes so blue is true Green
is the naive mid or so just an IE
regularization ignoring the desk spread
and red is using the bid-ask spreads and
you see neither is perfect but the green
one is much much easier confused it's
confused much faster by those our
supervised estimates it's already with
that simple trick it helps
also the other upside from this is that
because we're now in gold in a Gaussian
world because once we have interpreted
the desk spread as confidence intervals
then we're doing weighted least squares
regression and that doesn't only give us
a new fitted values it also gives us the
covariance matrix for the result so we
can look at the data at the covariance
so we now we can go the other way
take the confidence interval for our new
solution and interpret them as better
prayers for our quotes so for example
here you can see the region of the left
spreads we're super white partially but
if you believe that a curve math out
curve must be smooth then we can
generate much tighter black spread on
around which still which which still
contain the mid obviously don't try this
one poverty for real there's lots more
to regard when doing real good at
spreads but it can be a good it can be a
good starting point for your encoding
okay so far so simple now comes the
really fun part how can we do it over
time
and where and incidentally just in case
you're wondering where does they Zen
come in all the days and means is they
did have an a priori expectation and you
combine it with the observations to get
the ultimate result so here the a priori
expectation it was smoothness and the
values were what observed here however
now let's try to relate the same thing
over time and here where you should have
to to prior expectations so we have a
big point in time we were trying to get
a new value we have a previous
observation and we will have smoothness
as an expectation as well so I have
three things to combine smoothness
expectation previous value and new value
but to keep things simple for now let's
just let's go back from curves or single
points so this is the time series this
is the blue series as a random walk
which have only generated by summing out
brand of normal valuables and then I
generate it again the duck spreads
around it
some of them deliberately wide some type
so again what you observe is over time
just the green curve or just the green
bits and asks and your what you want to
do is to reconstruct the blue honest as
best you can
so let's try the first naive attempt
what do you think as always simple
approaches are the best so what do we do
we start with a super wide area
expectation we don't know what the value
is and then we just straight forward
based in math old value standard
deviation new value standard deviation
wait wait them with inverse squared
standard deviations combine less the new
value and the inverse of the sum of the
inverse standard deviation squares is
the new standard deviation standard math
okay
and let's try and see how it goes it
goes really really badly
that doesn't work who it's just have a
quick poll oh please raise the hands of
who thinks they know why doesn't work
okay so it doesn't work because our
implicit model is wrong because we think
what we did what we did would be true if
the thing had a constant MIT if we're
observing a series of this constant and
just know it's around around the one
value this will be the perfect algorithm
but we have a random walk and in fact
this random walk looks suspicious at
stationary so let's generate another one
arm which moves around a bit more yeah
so what what our green pitter is what
our green fitter is trying to do is to
estimate an unknown true true mid that's
unchanging and therefore you can see its
confident interval getting tighter and
tighter and tighter and it just but it's
way too sticking so instead we define
some way to represent in our model of
the concept that we have a random worker
things move around and that's the step
variance variable here and what this
does now if you look at this formula or
we have a standard deviation of our
prior estimate so if not just the
standard deviation we have in the
previous step but also the step variance
so we knew it was somewhere in here and
stepped in step by minus in this in step
T and now we know it diffused a bit so
the expectation value is the same but
the variance is bigger so every time
deform before combining before combining
the last our last observation with this
error variance with a new one have to
blow up the older there incident and
that's lovely way and by how much you
blow it up is a lovely way of
controlling how smooth or how reacting a
smoother is so let's try and run this
this is actually pretty good if you look
at it so the red curve it's obviously
confused a bit by the by the green one
but it's way way better than just
following the MS so if you have outliers
or they don't confuse you they confuse
you a bit of course because you don't
know what the truth is but it's got a
pretty good job of following and also
when it spreads it tight it stages
inside the tight spreads so it respects
the amount information we have
and this and this and this general idea
is a special case of Kalman filter which
so the general idea so we have a series
of estimates
each time so we have our current
estimates with this error we block we we
add another we add another area because
it's time is past and we add a new
observation crunch the mass and we have
a new anyone have an updated update
value updated salvation okay um so we
have some formulas here for those who
want to read them um but basically now
it's time to do to put it all together
and I'm going and deliberately going a
little fast here because L because again
look at the code is on github and I
think you've all had a long day last
thing you want to sit here for an hour
exhale hearing me talk so I'll talk I'll
talk you through this logic and then
some of the possible ways it could be
improved upon
already just in words and then can drill
into the AEDs you care about so now
let's put it together and let's the
curve across time and you think that
basic and you think you can imagine what
it is but there are a couple of twists
so let's generate generate submit and
now we can run several scenarios and the
biggest thing that distinguishes the
distinguish is a curve across time
fitting case from the from the top from
the simple time series case is that you
had a step variance in the type in the
case of Time series which is one number
determines how smooth how reactive fit
is and let's look and if you change so
if we change the step parents so that
the disk graph this is your normal case
with step parents of one if you have a
step variance of 0.1 so very little
diffusion between steps then
um sorry others oh yeah then we get a
really sticky so it's almost as bad
here
ah that's be okay that that's what comes
of running notebooks and not changing
the names between the notebooks I have
different things called mills right so
now see they have a really sticky step
variance then okay sorry about that here
then the fifth it does follow so that's
a long longer stuck in one place but
like Green was zero but it's much
thicker so the only the only thing you
can do by changing step variance which
is just one number in case of Time
series is control how sticky a time
series is which is useful but it's more
of a party trick however when you move
to the case of curves then your step
variance is actually a matrix it's a
covariance of of how your parameters
change in relation to each other over
time and with that thing you can do
tricks let me show you just a couple of
those tricks
so now because we have a curve I will I
will both across the curve across time
what I will do instead is every time i
refresh that cell the curve is the graph
will change update children yet the next
time step so this is a couple of
scenarios first scenario we start with
that slide with those slides of mids
okay so we just start blue is blue is
the initial observed midst random
generated around a sine curve and green
is the fit and we have a little
regularization and so you see that the
fit is just a touch smoother than the
blue curve nothing wrong and then as we
keep iterating all that happens is that
the given curve the fit gets smoother
and smoother and smoother and um and the
and the bid-ask spreads don't change
very much except this curve because
except this point which was very wide
now gets tighter because it's
interpolated from the from the neighbors
okay so far so boring now let's do some
fun stuff
um let us take point number two and this
is low which is the second scenario
let's take point number two and just
drag it
and just keep surveys which are really
really precise over just the point
number two and let's keep dragging this
point up and see what it does to the
rest of the curve and now I just I still
specify my step variance matrix as a
simple diagonal matrix so the way the
points I assume the way the parameter
weighs the parameters move across time
randomly I use uncorrelated okay how
does that go
fresh run beginning is pretty much the
same now let's start but you already see
the point number two the in the point
number two the bid-ask spread the green
one is ultra tight because we got an
observation there now let's try keep
refreshing it you see this point being
pulled up because there's no generation
there and the neighboring points are
being pulled up to cover the regular
eyes so this is so you have your food a
non parametric curve so the regularizer
works like a rubber band
you put one point up and the other
points follow the graph okay then maybe
that's not the way you would behave you
would wonder if you would want your
curve to behave normally if you're
trying to quote something you don't
really want the curve to deform and just
get fooled by the observation you have
you want the curve to keep its shape but
follow the points you have how can do
that so let's look at scenario three
where the step parents look at the step
covariance matrix is just all ones
rather than diagonal identity matrix
it's all one plus a little bit of an on
the diagonal
for just so it doesn't get generate
refresh so you see the only difference
between the previous one and this one is
the step variance so this for the first
point
so now what happens as one point moves
up you see the whole pair goes up so now
because we have a covariance matrix
which is all one this is basically a
plus Libet in the diagonal this
basically tells us that we assume at all
points are henry correlated so when we
observe just a point number two moving
up move the whole curve up and it's also
getting smoother but that's an optional
thing if you want to if you want to turn
on the regularizer that's not just and
it'll just move up yeah so I turned off
the regular Iser right and now as we
observe nothing else happens but the
whole curve gets pushed in this this
starts being useful if you if you're in
some kind of a weird market we only
observe one quote where you can only
observe one quote every 10 minutes um
credit some kind of a weird credits or
derivative who knows then this might
actually be useful because you know you
don't really what shape a curve has
except that it might be smooth ish and
you only see one chord at a time and
then maybe five minutes later you see
another quote another history but
obviously moving up and down is with
boring so let's do something else
um let's
let's make it do this and so basically
all you have to do is to say you define
a vector a long ways you should be easy
to move for example here I'm just taking
a range from 4 0 to 9 subtract from it
its own average multiply it by itself to
get a matrix and that's my new step
covariance matrix and this is here and
again and turn off the regular Iser so
it doesn't get in the way let's see how
that goes
the first one is exactly before and now
when I start pulling off the point
number 2 the curve does this so now
because of the life on track in my
matrix it does this and you don't know
it indefinitely one or the other
now you can have a weighted average of
the first and a second and then the
curve will be either shifting or tilting
but really reluctant to do anything else
and again note that this doesn't just
work with it with a simple curve where
every point where every point is a value
it could have worked just as easily if
you have some kind of a hidden
permutation in the back end kids the
fertilization in the back hand and then
do this and I'm not saying any of this
is rocket science of course but it's
exactly where it's useful so it's been
useful to me over and over again
now um that's why I think that's enough
code for one time now let me quickly go
over all the real world real world
problems which one is it because
obviously this is always nice and linear
real world doesn't work like that so
what can you do to make it actually
usable first one is hard inequality
constraints I'm sure most of you can
remember those bless at times when
interest rate was supposed to be
positive and we could just assume that
in a curve construction so you have to
observe that now this was a quadratic
optimization problem which you could
solve using linear algebra if you add
inequality constraints it stops you know
linear algebra and help anymore but it
becomes a quadratic programming problem
which means that is there's a solver for
that and the nice thing about erratic
programming problems
is that the solver guarantees the global
optimal solution and it's fast and this
is in fact how most and it's a good idea
to include inequality constraints just
to make sure I probably doesn't run away
to begin with then uh once you get into
the habit of adding soft consonants like
this there's regularization then you say
well maybe I want this value to be
somewhere around here
and when soft constraints multiply and
you can end up you're going to have with
hundreds trust me I've been there if you
had ones one of those one things that I
built based on this methodology is a
curve that was old tenors all from from
OAS overnight one day to 70 years IRS
again six months to my labor so all
tenors all durations and then is you can
imagine if you try doing into using this
kind of technology with where every node
where the curve could do something is a
parameter and then you have a rig then
you're up to your ears and regular
risers and then regular risers start to
work against each other in weird ways so
how can you mitigate that you get hard
equality constraints well because those
are all the deeds of our soft forms hard
equality constraints for example that's
a very fun exercise but for those of you
so inclined I know I enjoyed it
figuring out what are the Equality
constraints on the relations between
individual points to force the points to
lie on a quadratic spline and then if
you're doing it and then you can just
apply those as equality constraints on
the points the other fun trick is
hierarchical fitting you split your
problem into sections and if it section
a first using this and we take it as a
given at this section beef and that D
section B and so on and that there's a
lot of stabilize things because if you
had again if you had interest rate
interest rate futures oh is one month
and six month then certainly whatever
weird thing happens in the illiquid one
month should be driving our futures
curve so you want it to be hierarchical
and finally in my case I think when all
else fails you had parameterization I
don't really like permit ization because
I feel it constrains your options
so in things it depends you a problem if
you're doing some kind of if you need
your theory and your theory gives you
gives you a nice model like Sabre and
then by all means get that and even then
this is this stuff is useful so as as
far as I know um though you might well
still be using this methodology to pay
effects options using Sabre parameters
um but um then you can circulate
agnostic transparent rotation and here
again let me just drop off a thing to
follow up with everybody cares
my favorite permutation which is as
close to the nonparametric as you can is
bandwidth-limited parametrization
where what you have is you have Gaussian
on a grid which is one standard
deviation wide and your curve is a
linear combination of those gaussians
and your parameters and your weights are
your parameters and this way you can
so it's whole NICUs theorem a
bandwidth-limited see in the graph on
wikipedia but basically if you want to
curves that only do something
interesting over the step of one
standard deviation or more and for
example in Volcker fitting that's useful
then the kind of bandwidth-limited
linear combination gaussian thing can be
really useful because then for example
if you're pitting a vole curve I've
never been able to I've never seen a
proof but I think vole curves are
actually bandwidth limited on the step
of one of all on the step of one or log
X transpose so you only need so a vole
curve only really has even if you do it
on parametrically only really has like
seven degrees of freedom so because only
has seven foundation steps or like three
to each side
I would so then that could be useful
like poison
likewise in Volkers what you can do is
you can use one observation multiple
curves because obviously your puts on
your puts and calls depend importantly
apply it forward and on the wall and
then if you but then if you divide that
they are spread by the respective agree
you can use it in both the hitters and
your weight still works so the idea of
better spreads
being all those intervals still
translate
two final tricks on how to deal with
jumps because random walks are one nice
thing but when your price jumps which
they do sometime your random walk fails
you badly
the simplest way to deal with that is a
no memory common filter where your step
may tricks your step net experience is
so huge that every time you basically
forget all that happened before and
Fitz's in your data and if there is no
and your step matrix just works a weak
regularizer
like what we did in the very beginning
so you use your new data first and then
if there is any parameters left you use
your old data but don't you need to
jitter which comes to my other favorite
trick which is change detection
algorithms and change the text
algorithms it's a well known problem and
engineering Husum is one which is great
to the Committee on Wikipedia but most
change detector algorithms require
energy cell values but also have some
sort of standard deviation around them
so for example in cue sound what you're
saying is that what it basically does
one show you the formulas now unless you
want to is that if you have a standard
deviation and your values your deviation
from the mean of new values a deviation
of what your values from what you think
is the mean they're always to one side
of a stand more than couple sine
radiations then your mean is not true we
have a jump so event detection and so we
use that and then the nice thing about
these methods all of the things we
discuss today is that they don't just
give you new values on your estimates
they give you new standard deviations
for estimates so this is very naturally
with change detection so then what you
do is you run this thing assuming random
walk you're going to change the text
algorithm to the side and then if you in
the change detection it will change
detection triggers then you say oops I'm
out I'm on the wrong I'm in the wrong
position and then you fit in you and
then you just you reset fit a new state
keep on filling from the new states and
that includes that bag of tricks and if
you want to go deeper into any of this
please ask questions or grab nap to talk
sorry second we talked about computing
arithmetic feed trying to fix enterprise
to in fact in real life we look at
volume to start first um yes so how you
how you construct a bit of spread how do
you construct a confidence interval
let's vary the main dependent if you
have booked well if you trading
something ultra liquid those things are
probably not very useful because you
know where the mid is because it's
usually want equate anyway but then if
efforts if you have Google depth but
it's not that liquid then yeah good like
Luca fixed instance on the book depth or
do some kind of a waiting with these and
asks I mean this is obviously all these
a type problems but it's just a
direction so once you start interpreting
of the desk spreads as some that yields
you confidence intervals you can always
adapt it to the other main yeah um I
think Sabre is a curve with parameters
so you could use this as video Sabre
model where because Sabre is just
whatever your permutation lurks in
behind the curve
you wouldn't need regular risers as such
obviously because of the Sabre models or
you all you wouldn't you wouldn't e
regularizes because your models already
regular but you could still be very
useful to wait the point you fit using
the experts oh for sure and you could
also use this or to a to this for Sabre
and B to also control how mobile your
model is between points so how fast you
adapt your data and how fast you wait
how much you waited even your data
points
all right well it's been a long day
stuff so thanks again for coming here
and listening to me and if you have if
you want to know anything more of this
grab master talk
[Applause]
[Music]